[Music]
what's up guys
helen here today i want to talk about
that weird feeling i get in the pit of
my stomach
when hulu feeds me an ad like this
bullying the metoo movement against
sexual address masculinity
that's right advertising but make it
woke
woke advertising has become an
increasingly omnipresent phenomenon in
our media landscape
it's not enough to sell a hamburger you
gotta sell a mental health revolution
now i'm not saying i prefer the gross
advertisements of yesteryear
or even any ads at all however if you're
cynical like us
you probably feel a little weird about
your bath soap being imbued with
progressive new ideas about womanhood
in the interest of maintaining a healthy
skepticism toward anyone who's
ultimately trying to sell me more stuff
i've been wondering why does every
advertisement lately seem to come
furnished with a political message
and what does it mean for us welcome to
this wisecrack edition on how
advertising
got woke and hey if you hate ads
woke or otherwise there's a way you can
watch wisecrack videos without any brand
asking you to do anything by becoming a
patron you can watch all of our content
ad-free
it also helps us keep making great
in-depth content like this video
whether or not it's ad friendly check
out patreon.comwisecrack or click right
here to learn more
we have to start by asking what exactly
is
a woke ad is it when spaghettios tweets
about pearl harbor
or is it more like when ikea decides to
feature a gay couple back in 1994
or is it when nike pays colin kaepernick
to be a spokesperson precisely because
of his activism
we'd argue that woke advertising is
defined by its invocation of social
causes and social movements of a given
moment
especially those affiliated with
progress and social change
so sorry spaghettios you're not woke
that's not to say conservative brands
don't also try to capitalize on the
politics of their consumers
but nobody would call that woke
especially these days
woke ads typically focus on
identity-based issues surrounding race
gender sexuality disabilities and so
forth
in this way the kendall jenner pepsi ad
is woke
because it intended to align itself with
black lives matter
it just failed hilariously under this
definition
the secret deodorant ad in the 1970s
strong enough for a man
made for a woman was probably somewhat
woke for the feminist movement at the
time
but the same ethos and a cover girl add
in 2020 probably not
there's also the question of whether say
showing a female executive in an ad is
some woke affirmation of girl bosses
or just you know what professional life
is like today now
a lot of you might be screaming all
advertising is self-interested you big
dum-dum
companies are just trying to sell stuff
to as many people as possible
regardless of skin color sexual
orientation or gender
they're just getting with the times and
targeting their customers accordingly
whether that's two dudes putting their
relationship through the gauntlet of
building ikea furniture
together or just this guy who needs an
energy drink for gamers
or whoever needs this pink gamer chair
but economic reasons aside
what if it's just really bad for society
advertisements like any form of visual
or literary storytelling
have always been laden with values there
are reflections of our culture
and if our culture wants you to move to
the burbs and raise a family
that's what they're gonna reflect or if
society wants you to get rich and hot
ads will also reflect that but as values
change
ads naturally do too as a result and
contrary to popular belief
woke advertising is not at all a new
phenomenon
it's pretty old historically most woke
advertising appealed to women
overwhelmingly white by reflecting
various stages of the feminist movement
as explained by andy zeisler author of
we were feminists once in the late 19th
and early 20th century
when some younger women were feeling
stifled by victorian notions of
idealized womanhood
advertisers piggybacked off the existing
feminist notion
of the emancipated new woman by
frequently depicting young
independent gals who bucked against
victorian norms and even served on
juries
the new woman was according to zeissler
essentially a watered-down
more palatable suffragette who surprised
liked
buying things this conflict between the
advertiser-friendly new woman
and the ruckus-raising hunger-striking
suffragette is at the heart of the
problem with woke advertising
and it is maybe best illustrated by the
torches of freedom campaign
which very publicly debuted during a
parade in 1929.
it was masterminded by one edward
bernays the creator of modern public
relations and sigmund freud's nephew
bernays believed that people bought
things not based on what they needed
but based on the feelings a given
commodity inspired
so he organized a stunt to sell
cigarettes to women who were typically
looked down upon if they smoked outside
of their homes
he paid a group of debutants to light up
during new york's easter day parade
and made sure the event was both
captured by the press and interpreted as
a protest for women's rights
cigarettes were no longer just for men
they were torches of freedom
symbolizing female emancipation
fittingly the cigarette industry would
adapt its ads for the next phase of the
women's movement 40 years later when
virginia slims told women
you've come a long way baby as they sold
them cancer sticks
that 1968 tagline was in itself a
response to a growing threat for
advertisers
feminists no longer interested in
traditional beauty standards housework
and so on
might end up buying less lipstick and
clorox so
some savvy brands like charlie perfume
made like advertisers of yore and
incorporated elements of the feminist
movement
depicting a liberated bold woman who
held down a job and looked good while
doing it without explicitly using
controversial feminist language
in all of these examples we can see one
of the first dangers of woke advertising
it dilutes the political message of a
movement women
who were literally not allowed to apply
for a credit card without a male
undersigner
were asked to redirect their attention
to buying the feminist perfume
or the emancipatory cigarette why march
at all when you can consume
fittingly a similar phenomenon happened
to black americans
before the civil rights movement and the
rise of the black middle class in the
1950s
advertising to people of color was
virtually non-existent
advertisers had simply always targeted
white americans
feud in that framework mainstream ads
showing black people at all was
at face value sadly kind of progressive
some of the first companies to even
advertise in black run newspapers were
you guessed it cigarette companies the
reason they did it is
pretty instructive internal documents
for tobacco company brown and williamson
report that in the case of black and
hispanic communities
the relatively small and often tightly
knit minority community
can work to bnw's marketing advantage
if exploited properly and just like with
the feminist movement
as the burgeoning civil rights movement
made headway adds began
co-opting imagery associated with black
power none more bluntly than this 1970
jcpenney ad that reads slack power
as historian stuart ewen put it at the
time the advertising industry
seeking markets has generated a mass
culture which reflects the spirits
but not the cutting edge of this
resistance but by the 1980s
our contemporary brand of woke
advertising was
really coming into its own again aimed
primarily at white women
in what zeissler calls empowertizing
this was a time when consumer choices
exploded and consumption became elevated
as a measure of liberation
as cultural historian and media critic
susan j douglas put it
elitism and narcissism merged in a
perfect appeal to forget the political
already
and get back to the personal which you
might be able to do something about
specifically by buying those designer
eyeglasses you could change your small
corner of the world
ads would continue to capitalize off of
feminist critiques of mass consumer
culture
as seen in this nike ad campaign in the
early 90s
what's so interesting about this ad is
the way it specifically invokes the pain
of women living in a world that judges
them overwhelmingly by their appearance
rather than being judged by curves it
reads a woman should be judged by who
she is and who she is trying to become
this leads to another serious problem
with woke advertising
if all advertising sells dreams woke ads
tend to sell the dream of respect and
equality
reading this ad stirs real emotions
literally making
oprah cry on air ad sell solutions
whether it's for your leaky whatever or
your untoned arms
the solution nike is selling in this
case is the solution
to sexism you're not buying a running
shoe made in a sweatshop
you're buying equality and respect the
guiding principle
shopping but make it feminist it's also
worth noting that the feminism of nike
was
anything but as a coalition of women's
groups said at the time
while the women who wear nike shoes in
the united states are encouraged to
perform their personal best
the indonesian vietnamese and chinese
women
making the shoes often suffer from
inadequate wages
corporal punishment forced overtime and
or sexual harassment
women weren't the only group being
targeted by woke advertising at the turn
of the century though
the aforementioned ikea ad was only the
first of many active campaigns by
corporations to court so-called
queer dollars as author alexandra chason
explains in her book
selling out such courting of the queer
market
was said to signal an end to homophobia
this can most visibly be seen in the
rise of
everything rainbow in recent decades an
effective co-opting of the rainbow flag
designed by gay activist gilbert baker
in the late 70s
everything from rainbow underwear to
rainbow instagram images
to rainbow chipotle burritos purport to
celebrate queerness
while really elevating the simple act of
buying
walk is and always will be extra as
jason puts it when describing rainbow
clothes
the reduction of politics to style
implies that consumption
can amount to political change attempts
to imbue
advertising with woke messaging became
increasingly more explicit throughout
the 2000s
best exemplified by the ubiquity of this
is what a feminist looks like
shirts which literalize the notion that
buying the right thing
signals your commitment to the cause of
women's rights and in the past five
years
as feminism has become increasingly less
taboo advertising that co-ops feminist
language has become all but ubiquitous
that's not surprising woke advertising
generally supports the status quo
with risk-averse corporations typically
choosing to piggyback off of existing
social change
rather than furthering it in this lens
it's no surprise that beyonce's 2014
feminist vmas moment was followed by an
explosion of brands evoking feminism
queen bee made it safe and advertising
followed
what's really interesting about these
ads is that they have nothing to do with
the product
and everything to do with exploring the
pain and oppression women and girls face
dubbed hashtag
femvertising for their purportedly
feminist messaging
these ads almost guaranteed to tug at
the heartstrings
this is already a reason to be wary
remember edward bernays
it's not about the product it's about
the way the product makes you feel
and if these sanitary napkins make you
feel sad for the way your 12 year old
self was pigeonholed
you're more likely to buy them perhaps
after seeing the rampant success of
femvertising
corporations have in recent years begun
to explicitly draw on black activism for
inspiration a procter and gamble ad from
2017
shows several black parents talking to
their children about the racism they
will inevitably encounter
it concludes by imagining a world where
such conversations are not necessary
as with women's ads these ads draw on
real pain
while offering wish fulfillment by
imagining a less racist future
sound a little manipulative never is
this more apparent than in that widely
panned pepsi ad
in which kendall jenner dissolves
tensions between the police and
protesters with a can of soda
ironically this ad functions like a much
less subtle version of 1971's
i'd like to buy the world of coke aired
in the midst of the vietnam war and
massive social upheaval
it simply implied that if everyone
chilled out with a carbonated beverage
wars and stuff wouldn't happen
it went on to receive countless
accolades inspired fan mail
and as a song even charted in several
countries
but the jenner pepsi ad somehow crossed
a threshold of believability
by making all too obvious the
implication
that a pepsi could end racism on the
other hand
brands are also eager to exploit the
credibility earned by activists to sell
more stuff
advertisers today are dealing with
similar issues that they faced from
social issues of the last century
but maybe a little more so millennial
and gen z consumers
overwhelmingly say that they prefer to
buy from brands that share their values
or
have a higher purpose that is we want to
know that our coffee is helping some
farmer in nicaragua send their kids to
school or that our beans do or don't
support the right presidential candidate
but there's another force pushing this
change today
products are increasingly disappearing
from advertisements
which instead promote the more nebulous
brand scholar nikki lisa cole ties this
transformation to the increased
outsourcing of production
leaving corporations progressively more
detached from the actual products they
made
as cole puts it companies used to stand
on a product
that was your name the product you made
but when you don't actually make the
product you have to come up with
something else to sell to people
that thing of course is a brand and in
many cases
a hashtag woke brand as a result
brands are doing another new thing
something we've mentioned in previous
videos
they're becoming people woke people
the rise of social media has enabled a
host of new usually painful ways for
brands to interact with potential
consumers
and interact they do especially if it
means making themselves look noble
brands increasingly are placing
themselves at the center of flashpoint
cultural issues
a bloomberg analysis found that within
three weeks of the murder of george
floyd
76 of the world's top 100 brands had
posted at least one corporate statement
about racial justice
in this instagram post fisa managed to
incorporate two phrases iconic to its
advertising
turning its slogan everywhere you want
to be into where we want to be
and slyly including part of their
messaging accepted everywhere
meanwhile zara the fast fashion company
made infamous in 2016 for profiting off
of child labor
posted a black square that mostly
yielded inpatient comments from
customers
complaining about late shipping this
queasy moment encapsulates the uneasy
relationship
between commerce and social justice
while some saw the quote unquote
blackout as great for pr
many criticized it as co-opting a
campaign conceived by black musicians
and activists who were drowned out amid
a sea of corporate sponsored and
performative black squares
when the ceo of jpmorgan chase took a
knee to invoke colin kaepernick
diversity consultant wyvon hutchinson
responded by telling the washington post
that
there's a lot of performative allyship
going around nobody's asking for a ceo
to take a knee
you take the knee after you change your
policies and
of course as with feminism it's not a
coincidence that this outpouring of
corporate support comes at a time when
calls and support for ending police
brutality is at an all-time high
in other words they'll support black
lives matter when it's least
controversial
most convenient and financially safe to
do so which is why i want to tell you
right here and now that wisecrack is
committed to ensuring all women can
apply for
and use credit cards without mail
supervision
and you can take a stand right now with
us by taking your credit card and using
it to become a patron
not only will you send a strong message
to sexist credit card companies
but you'll get ad-free and early access
to all of our videos
plus higher levels get you access to
cool stuff like the wisecrack discord
where you can hang out with wisecrack
staff and fans be sure to let everyone
know in their how much you support
my right to incessantly order takeout
even when i have a fully stocked fridge
check it out and make a stand by going
to patreon.com
wisecrack and as always thanks for
watching
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]